This episode of DNews is brought to you by
JackThreads.
Do you wanna know what color gets ME in the
mood?
hey guys, Julia here for DNews
The colors man, the colors!
If you’re not completely color blind, kid,
you might associate certain colors with certain
feelings.
But the idea that colors affect moods seems
like.. well like baloney to me.
But studies as far back as the 1930s show
that people, at least in the Western world
associate colors with specific feelings.
We use colors as metaphors for emotions.
Red represents anger, while blue is seen as
serene and dignified.
A study published more recently in BMC Medical
Research Methodology found this to hold true.
Some healthy people picked a happy yellow
as associated with their mood, while some
people with depression and some people with
anxiety picked shades of grey to describe
their mood.
Colors can even change the way drugs work.
Seriously.
The color blue makes for better sedatives
while red makes stimulants more effective.
Speaking of red… there really seems to be
some strong feels surrounding the hot hue.
Red seems to be a universal color that means
stop, danger or hot.
While you might think this has to do with
culture it might have to do with our biology.
One study in the journal Emotion found that
when people see red they react stronger and
faster.
Red is often seen as the sexy color, and one
study published in the Journal of Experimental
Social Psychology found that to hold up across
different cultures.
But it’s not just people, one study published
in Psychological Science found that male rhesus
macaques avoid or act submissively around
someone who wears red.
Another study published in the journal Evolution
and Human Behavior found that female macaques
tend to gaze longer at images of male hindquarters
surrounded by frames of red than the same
image framed with blue.
So maybe the roots of red reactions lie deep
within our DNA.
Some scientists think this could because red
is so important for communication.
A flushed face could signal that someone is
angry or ready to hit the sheets.
But other colors carry meaning too.
Kermit would be happy to know that it’s
pretty easy, well calming being around green.
One study published in environmental science
and technology found that the color green
might make you enjoy your workout more.
The researchers found that men who looked
at the color green while working out were
less tired and had less mood disturbances.
Other studies show that colors with shorter
wavelengths like blue and green evoke feelings
of calmness.
A study published in Applied Psychology: Health
and Well-Being found that kids with ADHD experience
fewer symptoms after playing in an outdoor
green space.
Green might also help enhance your creativity,
according to a study published in the journal
Personality and Social Psychology Bulletin.
These benefits of green might be because a
lush green landscape meant a fertile land
with plenty of food for our ancestors.
Blue can mean a few different things.
One shade might be calming while a darker
hue might signal sadness.
But blue light might perk us up.
One reason might be because blue acts on our
biological clock.
On a bright sunny day, the sky is a brilliant
blue, telling us to be awake.
This is one of the reasons why the blue light
from your laptop and phone screens can keep
you awake at night.
So if you want to get pumped up, you should
be seeing red.
Want to calm down?
Surround yourself with hues of blue and green.
And if you want to put yourself and others
in a good mood, try changing the color of
your shirt!
For all you guys out there, try JackThreads.
JackThreads is the only place you need to
shop to find the best gear that won’t break
the bank.
They have stylists on call to make shopping
a no-brainer, plus tons of great brands to
select from.
On top of the already great prices, Get an
additional 15% off by visiting JackThreads.com/DNews
and entering coupon code DNews at checkout.
Speaking of color, have you ever wondered
if we all see the same color?
Like is your red the same as my red? or is
your red like my blue?
Check out this video here Anthony throws on
his rose-colored glasses and takes a look.